we're told consider the sum 2 plus 5
plus 8 plus 11 which expression is equal
to the sum above and they tell us choose
all answers that apply
so like always pause the video and see
if you can work through this on your own
so when you look at the sum it's clear
you're starting at two you're adding
three each time
and we also are dealing with
you have four total terms now we could
try to construct an equation here or an
expression using sigma notation but
instead what i like to do is look at our
options we really only have to look at
these two options here and expand them
out what sum would each of these be
well this is going to be the same thing
as we're starting at n equals 1. so this
is going to be 3 times when n equals 1 3
times 1 minus 1 and then plus then we'll
go to n equals 2.
3 times 2
minus 1. then we're going to go to n
equals 3 so plus
3 times 3
minus 1. and then finally we're going to
go to n equals 4. so plus 3 times when n
equals 4 this is 3 times 4
minus 1. so just to be clear this is
what we did when n equals 1. let me
write it down n equals 1.
this is what we got when n equals 2.
this is what we got when n equals
3. and this is what we got when n is
equal to
four
and we stopped at n equals four because
that tells us right over there we go we
start at n equals one and we go all the
way to n equals four so what does this
equal so
let's see 3 times 1 minus 1 is 2 so this
is looking good so far
3 times 2 minus 1 that's 6 minus 1 that
is 5 so still looking good 3 times three
minus one that's nine minus one once
again still looking good three times
four minus one that is eleven
so we like this choice so i would
definitely select this one now let's do
the same thing over here when n is equal
to 0 it's going to be 2 plus
3 times 0 so that's just going to be 2
and then plus when n is equal to 1 it's
going to be 2 plus 3 times 1 which is 5.
this is starting to look good
now when n is equal to this was n equals
0 this was n equals 1 so now we're at n
equals 2. so at n equals 2 2
plus 3 times 2
is 2 plus 6 which is 8. and this makes
sense every time we increase n by 1
we are adding another 3 which is
consistent what we saw there we start at
2 when n equals 0 this is just that 3n
is just 0. so you start at 2 and then
you keep every time you increase n by 1
you are just adding 3 again so finally
when n is equal to 3 2 plus 3 times 3 is
2 plus
or is
11 i should say and so this also is
exactly the same sum
so i feel good about
both of these
let's do one more example
so we're here we're given the sum and
we're saying choose one answer which of
these is equivalent to this sum right
over here
well like we did before let's just
expand it out and what's different here
is that we just have a variable but that
shouldn't make it too much more
difficult so let's do the situation and
i'll write it out let's do the situation
when n is equal to one
when n is equal to one it's going to be
k over
one plus one
k over one plus one and i'll write it
out this is n is equal to 1 and then
plus
when n is equal to 2 is going to be k
over 2 plus 1.
this is n is equal to 2.
and then we're going to keep going when
n is equal to 3 it's going to be k
over 3 plus 1
that's n is equal to 3
and then plus finally because we stop
right over here at n equals 4 when n
equals 4 it's going to be k
over
4 plus 1
that's when n is equal to 4.
so this is all going to be equal i'll
just write it over here this is equal to
k over 2 plus k
over 3
plus k
over 4
plus k over 5
which is exactly this choice right
over
right over here and actually if i had
looked at the choices ahead of time i
might have even be able to save even
more time by just saying
well look
actually if you just try to compute the
first term when n is equal to 1 it would
be k over 2. well only this one is
starting with a k over 2. this this one
has no case here which is sketchy
they're trying to look at the error
where you try to replace the k with the
number as well not just the n so that's
what they're trying to do here
here they're trying to let's see well
this this isn't as obvious what they're
even trying to do what right over here
where they put the k in the denominator
and here if you swapped the n and the
k's then you would have gotten this
thing right over here so we definitely
feel good about choice a